energy bills are going to go through the
roof this winter which is why we the
labour party have said we should freeze
energy prices not let those bills go up
and pay for that in part with the
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
are making huge huge profits alongside
that we need a national mission to
insulate homes that's a longer term
issue i called for that a year ago now
if the government had done that we'd
have the best part of two million homes
insulated this morning i've been seeing
next generation homes with insulation
built into them so we need to freeze
prices for this winter but we need a
longer term answer that's insulating
homes and national mission instead of an
attribution we've got a zombie
government and that's the root of the
problem
i mean how does this practically work i
mean how much is this going to cost i
know it could save consumers money in
the long term but surely the
government's going to have to part fund
this well i've been uh talking about
this building block here and it's quite
clear that the building costs are not
much higher than the ordinary cost of
building a block but it will be energy
efficient so two things are needed
freeze those energy bills this winter
using a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies making huge profits alongside
that a national mission to insulate our
homes millions of people are heating
their homes and losing most of that
because they're not properly insulated
that's why i called a year ago for a
national mission on this if the
government had actually done something
we'd have two million homes insulated
right now that'd be people with much
much lower bills and we can't go on like
this with a government that's absolutely
missing in action in the middle of a
cost of living crisis
you talk about a zombie government there
are missing in action then isn't it
sensible if liz cross becomes prime
minister that she doesn't need an obr
forecast that she needs to get on and
make decisions have an emergency budget
maybe as soon as possible we need an
emergency budget we should have had that
months ago to deal with the cost of
living crisis but the obr is there to
make sure that money is spent wisely and
properly so of course you need the obr
in place for that and i think that's why
there's been such a reaction to liz
truss's proposal that she's going to
just put that to one side but more
important than that what we need to hear
is what are you going to do
about the cost of living crisis labor is
leading on this we've said freeze those
bills this winter make sure people don't
pay any more for their energy prices
alongside that have an insulation scheme
that means that in the middle and long
run we actually have a better answer to
the energy crisis that we're in the
middle of
just a few other things criminal
barristers do you support them going on
strike well i quite understand whether
it's barristers or others uh why people
and how people are struggling to make
ends meet and what i want to see is the
government to recognize that do
something about it resolve these issues
in whichever sector they are but also
have bigger picture answers
the answer for many many people in terms
of bills is things like freezing the
energy prices because that's going to
drive people even further into problems
with their bills this winter so i want
to see the government step in and
actually help resolve these issues
instead that we've got the government
doing absolutely nothing but it's saying
that we've got strikes with barristers
with dockers essentially in felix stowe
rail staff i mean our labor in favor of
these strikes not only the public know
whether you're in favor of them against
them or pretty apathetic towards them
i want to see these issues resolved many
working people are really struggling to
make ends meet
labour understands that that's why we
put our proposal on the table to freeze
energy prices because that's one way of
ensuring not only that those prices
don't go up this winter but we bring
inflation down our plan to freeze prices
means inflation comes down by four
percent that's a big driver of many of
these um issues so we want to resolve
these issues the government is sitting
on its hands doing absolutely nothing
just very finely
very sadly for tyson fury loss
relative to his over the weekend in a
stabbing he's calling for stronger
sentences when it comes to knife crime
is that something that you the labour
party supports
well the first thing i'd say is
obviously our thoughts are with him and
his family and friends for their tragic
loss i do think we've got to address
knife crime i think that is to do with
sentences it's also to do with the
support that we need in our communities
the government's ripped all of the money
out of youth services
and they're all interlinked so yes we do
need action on this
and i think it's time for us all to come
together to make sure that we put our
shoulder to the wheel on this